good evening welcome to statford on aen
District Council planning committee my
name is councelor Lewis Adam I'm your
chairman for this evening uh just some
housekeeping to begin with uh there's no
fire drill plan so if it does go off um
please make an orderly exit and uh the
uh muster point is across the road in
the car park by the pub where we'll
check names off uh can you please make
sure your phones are all on silent or
turned off so they don't uh distract the
flow of the meeting uh this is a meeting
in public not a public meeting so only
those registered to speak will be able
to do so um they'll be called forward at
the appropriate time and given further
instruction at that point the meeting is
being recorded and broadcast on our
website uh I'll now introduce the top
table um from democratic Services we've
got Cara K our solicor this evening is
Amy Shipley our planning manager is
David Jeffrey and our plan planning
officers in no particular order are
Victoria Kempton Tony Horton and Sarah
flatty and I believe David has a
statement he's
prepared thank you chair my name is
David Jeffrey I'm the planning manager
for tonight's meeting my role is to
provide impartial advice to clarify any
planning issues that arise and to assist
members decision taking um planning
committee members are not bound by
advice from officers or their
recommendations thank you very much okay
okay we can now move on to the agenda
then item one is apologies for
absence we have apologies from
councilors Curtis and Harvey with
councelor littlewood a
substitute thank you very much item two
disclosures of
Interest Council
Perry uh thank you chair I'd like to um
advise a disclosure of in interest for
application number
290 which is the mini golf um I've been
playing the game for over 60 years I'm a
former golf journalist I've represented
uh the Ridder cup LPGA
PGA uh and currently play for wara and I
just feel I might be a little bit biased
thank you
chair thank you Council Parry noted
Council Kei yeah just thank you chair
just to confirm I was at the site visit
this afternoon but I come with an open
mind
to application
23637 at T Fields thank you thank you
very much um and that goes for Council
Perry as well um I'll note as well that
disclosure interest for myself I
attended the site visit and I come with
an open mind um I was also contacted by
I believe the agent for that application
as I believe other members were so yeah
we'll do this blanket any further
disclosures
okay we can now move on then to item
three which is our first application um
application
23126 6fy welfare center Craven Lane
salum our presenting officer is Victoria
Kempton when you're ready take it
away thank you chairman and good evening
so this application is cited within the
town center of sou and location is
marked by the black dot on the map
permission is sought to vary condition
two of a previous planning application
for one new dwelling the proposed
changes are to increase the ease height
resulting in external and internal
changes to the
design this slide outlines the site in
red which is located
here sorry it's located here the site is
within the conservation area as
indicated by The Continuous purple line
whilst being near grade two listed
buildings which are the solid red
lines this slide shows the proposed
elevations of the dwelling which would
be which would include traditional
detailing and arched windows at ground
floor level the materials were
originally proposed to include red brick
walls gray fiber faake tiles and white
Windows here is a comparison between the
approved elevations of the home with a
lower ease height and proposed
elevations being considered under this
application the key change is that the
eaves height will be increased by around
1.4 M and the dmer windows on the rear
elevations will be removed a side facing
window has also been added to the east
facing elevation there will be no
changes to the Bridge height sighting or
footprint the floor plans show the
internal layout of the accommodation The
increased e Eaves height and removal of
the Doral window would allow for an
addition of one bedroom to create a
three bedroom
dwelling
site photo number one shows the existing
welfare center on the site which is
proposed for demolition photo number two
shows the car parking areas which wrap
around the site to the side and rear
whilst photo number three shows the
relationship of number one Craven Lane
which would have a side to side
relationship the property is also on a
lower level than the
site these photos show a view taken from
opposite the site looking into the east
um to number one showing the character
of the dwellings in this direction
second photo is taken adjacent to the
site looking opposite to number
11 this street view image shows how the
site relates to the surrounding
development and how the building Heights
vary overall the application is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions and there are a couple of
clarifications on the update sheet um
and this concludes my presentation thank
you chairman thank you very much okay we
can now move on to to our first speakers
then who are Mr D mini and Mr Allan
Wright yeah if you just like to come
up um so you've got three minutes
between you um
yes uh I'm afraid it's because you're I
tell you're both objecting that's you
both down as objectors in which case you
share the time I'm
afraid right I'm sorry about that
um on that basis how would you like to
split the
time I mean I I can I can give you a
sort
of yeah um B two
seconds yeah I'm I'm sorry that's that's
the time allocated for for obors with uh
in in total
um yeah okay well I I'll let you know um
which case I'm going to let you know
when you've got um a minute elapsed and
uh I'll let you know when a minute and a
half is finished okay thank you very
much um in which case if you could just
press the button on the right hand side
make the microphone live yep and you can
start when you're ready right um I
abducted these plans I live at number 11
which was just shown you can see that is
a very small house it is only 1.5
stories high um with roof
lights now when this is built I object
because it is going to increase the
height of the um of the new property
it's a complete redesign of the Upper
Floor um we went it was going to have
roof lights also I've quered the
distance between we had the building a
planning inspectorates report which said
that the previous previous applications
were too
close um and this one should be 13 M
back but it is only 12 but the case
officer that passed it uh application
three as I call it she informed me that
she was happy with the 12 M as both
buildings had roof lights and no
overlooking
Windows this obviously played a big part
in her approving application 3 but now
we are back to where we started with
Windows overlooking into the skylights
of my
bedroom with application three being
approved at a separation distance of 12
M instead of 13 I've I have given a
meter or 39 in the applicant has now
submitted revised plans reducing the
height of the Eaves by 150 mm or 5.9 in
I find that totally insulting to
everybody concerned that's a minute and
a half sorry that's minute and
that's a minute and a half right you
want to do yours
Dave I represent number one Craven Lane
now Planning Commission was granted in
April something that wasn't ideal but
there was Skylight Windows now this is
going back to normal Windows now in that
case we're looking at
now before um you couldn't see into our
yard and also my brother's disabled and
the two side windows of number one
Craven Lane they are his living
conditions in the
yard um and the change of the height the
change the change of the the plan is
going to affect the right of light
because of the change of the roof I
wasn't happy with the first lot of plans
but I accepted it because it wasn't
invading their privacy where now it is
because if you got through front windows
that be had to see into our yard now
I've got two disabled people at number
one crav lane at a houseband the only
time they go out is to the doctors or
hospitals Mr W also has health
conditions and doesn't get out the house
very much and this is going to have a a
detrimental effect on our living
conditions and I speak with passion
because it's my mom's house and my dad's
house since
1966 and I hope you would turn these
plans down you
know and think about the residents
long-term residents since 1966 Mr W 17
years and the third person who's not
here who've been in the road for 20
years they also didn't agree with the
change in
plans okay thank you that that was bang
on your time but thank you very much
thank you very much commit oh um so if
you just stay there a second um
typically at this point we
have um questions to the to the speaker
um so if you'd both like to come up and
um we just see if the members have any
questions for you uh members do we have
any questions uh councelor
Parry thank you chair I'd like to ask
the first Speaker a question if I may
you mentioned you showed on the slide
presentation you've got skylights in
your particular property can you give us
some indication as to how far off the
ground off the ground level on the on
the first floor that they sit because
they're obviously at an angle yeah um
are they the bed the bedroom wall is
probably as high as this desk so that's
all that the bedroom when you're
standing then the roof then the roof
takes yeah so when you're so if I get if
I go to the windows yes I'll rub my head
on on the Windows if I can explain it
way so the the angle of um um the yeah
if you stand um by the Skylight you can
see out can you I will see straight into
the windows that are being proposed and
they will see straight into
mine any further questions uh councelor
Keith Le yes thank you chairman a
question for the second speaker you
mentioned that the uh change in plan for
the building would mean that the um
occupant would be able to see straight
over into your living space downstairs
do you mean by that that they will see
out of the rear bedroom windows straight
into your yard or from the side it's the
front ones as it's set on the side I she
set next door to it when as it's set
back because it's got to be 13 meters
from number one Craven Lane uh from
number 11 Craven Lane it's got to be set
back well our yard goes all the way down
to the bottom and it's private with a 7
foot wall and a 7 fence all the way
around so when they had skylights in in
them you you wouldn't be looking into
our garden space ah so they're
overlooking your garden garden which two
disa people sitting in the summer
because they they're housebound and your
brother's bedroom and my brother's
bedroom is downstairs we can't go
upstairs and then two windows at the
side of the house um at the side there's
living conditions there his living room
and his bedroom which I don't think you
can see on your so in our yard you got
two
windows and they are his living
conditions his bedroom and
his kitchen and bathroom area okay
thanks I'll ask clarification from the
officers in a minute thank you any
further questions for our
residents no in which case thank you
very much for your contribution this
evening uh so our next speaker is the W
member councelor
Crump good evening counc
councelor obviously you know the drill
um You Got 5 minutes I'll give you a 30
second
warning you'll see a different side to
me tday
yeah no puns good grief I do hope not
trying to put a court in a point part so
ready yeah thank you this site has come
forward several times as you can see
from the planning and appeals history in
the officers report this is the third
time I've been here to share my concerns
about this development in principle I
have no issue with the development on
the site even though it has a special
place in southern resident hearts on a
supported the application that was
granted on the 26th of April this year
on the hway address mine and residents
concerns unbalanced officer got the
decision right on the other two
occasions firstly two times two bedroom
houses with no parking contrary to our
parking SPD and secondly a 2.5
three-story house that was dominant in
the streets in and severely impacted
close neighbors I think the officers got
it around and as an ex local government
officer 30 plus years I do not like to
criticize staff especially as to deal
deal with strange CCS like myself my
concerns on objections and the decisions
of this committee were Justified and
validated by two appeals that apphow the
decision to refuse these applications it
was pleasing to see that local residents
views who were affected by this 24/7
were heard it is notable that neither
the alleged supporters nor the agent for
this application have bothered to turn
up tonight I do know that the officer of
the application thought this was a
finally balanced decision as I believe
she was airing on the side of refusal at
one stage we must remember there is
already an extand and acceptable
planning approval for the site so
there's no need to accept this
unsuitable and substandard in terms of
occupi imunity and separation distes
application I feel that changes to the
eaves on the front elevation caused the
most impact to the front to front
relationship with number four and the
two side facing windows on number five I
find that there would be an increased
impact on the upon the shadowing to the
solid facing Windows number one meaning
both Coast neighbors are
affected whilst the effect of such
changes is reduced at the rear of
property number one by the removal of
the D window it is the front slope
changes which would cause the most
impact upon the neighboring Windows this
would in turn result in a greater
cumulative impact given the proximity of
the development to the neighboring
dwelling particularly the window serving
the land and bedroom and I know that Eve
Heights are important to this committee
recently in sa them at Hilltop Hillard
Road they formed part of the reason for
refusal I believe in my opinion I think
the harm is material enough to Warrant
refusal especially as one of the
neighbors Windows would only return a
proportion of the views of Open Sky to
the South concerns have been raised that
development wouldn't even meet
separation distances as part of rspd
requirements in the report it states
that the front elevations of the
properties are 11.7 M which would be
under the minimum 13 met separate
conditions then the agent overlaid the
satellite imagery land registry map and
the proposed development to plot the
position of the neighboring roof light
and found there was potential tolerance
in the distance from the first war to be
12.9 M which are the right figures have
they been verified it certainly
undermines competence in these figures I
assume once the officer raised the issue
with the agent the distance miraculously
improved by over 10% even then they
still couldn't amend it to actually meet
our distances or be it only slightly but
that's not the point we have a 10.6 year
hous and land Supply so we don't have to
accept applications that are below our
standards the same applies to the Garden
serving the dwelling that will be 40
square meters which is below 20% below
the recommended 50 m Square air or put
another way would need to be increased
by 25% to meet the standard in the
report it states that due to the
internal a challenges the proposed
elment will be increased to from two to
three bedrooms therefore it is not
unreasonable to soon this is likely that
the children will be living in this
property play areas in such a small area
would would certainly be more limited
than normal and as an authority we need
to encourage people particularly young
people to be outdoor and have access to
exercise opportunities which is good for
mental health obesity Etc finally The
Proposal includes a side facing window
which could be conditioned as obscure
glazing to prevent any harmful
overlooking impact this is
acknowledgement of the harmful impact
and I don't think this is suitable is
even this month we've had 30°
temperatures and last year nearly 40 de
in such cases I I can imagine the window
would not just be open but fully open
enabling overlooking of the garden and
the gate in this condition in conclusion
there is already an extent and
acceptable planning approval for the
site so there's no need to accept this
unsuitable and substandard application
we already have a 10e plus housing land
Supply so we should be seeking quality
homes that don't adversely impact
neighbors I find that would be an
increased impact upon the
overshadowing uh to the side facing
Windows of number one I feel the the
increase in the E would increase the bul
and scale of the dring to an extent to
which it would increase the overbearing
overshadowing impacts to the laboring
property number one I respectfully
request that committee goes against
officer recommendation to refuse this
application for the reasons I've
highlighted within this report thank you
with about two seconds to
spare two seconds spare thank you very
much counselor uh members do we have any
questions councelor Keithley first yeah
thank thank you chairman uh good evening
councelor Crump um thank you very much
for that I one point of clarification um
you mentioned the size of the garden you
said it was 40 square meters which is
under the standard that's required can I
ask you if you know whether or not the
garden is the same size as the garden
that was already
granted um in in the application 593
which you which you said that you were
happy with to be honest it
I don't but the reason it matters now
because we were prepared to make a
compromise that on that previous
application and it was the lesser of two
evils or four evils in the amount of
applications that's come through on this
one so you we took the pragmatic and
realistic re view that yes it might be
slightly um lower than the norm and I
can't remember what it is it might be
might not so the officer might be able
to help you with that
but the cumulative effect of the
increased in height by 1.45 m uh the
overshadowing potential need to have
obscure
glazing um lower and separation the
distances it's the combination of the
two so it's I probably you know that's
the real reason so we've raised it now
but we were willing to accept it because
the eite wasn't so big and there wasn't
the overlooking and the broken Mass so
so I can I can see see where you're
coming from why wasn't this mentioned
before and that's the
reasons okay thank you I just needed to
clarify in my own mind that one of the
issues that you raised was the size of
the garden but you mentioned that you
were happy with the previous application
I just wanted to make sure that the
Garden Was the Same Size because I I
yeah no I I take your point but what I'm
saying is we were prepared to make
allowances for for the good of the whole
whole scheme but now the scheme has
changed
significantly we we're going to complain
about that so we might as well complain
about this thank you any further
questions for our Ward
member no in which case thank you very
much counc
Crump okay uh we can now move on then to
points of clarification for our officers
councilor holes jumping in
first um hello uh in the update report
um talks about how officers have
considered that there's insufficient
harm by the way of overbearing and
overshadowing um has anything you've
heard uh this evening so far change your
opinion on that at
all um the impact on the garden was
carefully considered at the point of
determination um and and there was some
um commentary on it as well given that
the house was set back from the road
leaving around four or five meters to
the front of it and front section of the
garden unaffected so hearing what we've
heard today um wouldn't change um the
recommendations thank you chairman um
yes point of
clarification in in respect of the
overlooking into number one that was a
question I asked of the um second
speaker Victoria could you just help me
understand whether or not in the new
scheme the rear windows of the bedrooms
are any higher or any bigger than the
old scheme are they moved back a by 5 m
but are the windows now with the EES
height increased in a different position
to the windows that were approved when
they were Dorma Windows does that make
sense yes it does thank you um so I've
got a bit of a comparison of the
approved proposal and what's been
proposed tonight on the um screen which
shows the position of um the windows the
changes in the internal layouts does
does affect the um whether they're
habitable rooms or not um but the
position of them are very
similar might I just clarify that so for
me so what I'm looking at is in in those
plans those elevations I'm looking at
the re rear elevation the top one is the
approved scheme and the upstairs windows
are Dormer bedroom windows look the
windows in a dormer aren't they and the
lower plan the rear elevation shows the
windows as they'll appear immediately
under the
EES um that's correct I believe that one
of the dormal windows for um in in this
one I believe one one served a bedroom
slash study um where now I believe
they're both to serve a
bedroom okay right so so the windows in
the same position effectively but
they've moved back by 5
m is the whole house moved back there's
no change in the sighting of of the
house um there'll be some slight changes
very minor as to the position of the
windows in the house um given that there
rather than being on the exterior wall
there were would be on um the rear of
the door window okay thank you coun
Perry thank you um Victor I just wonder
whether you might know what the height
is from the ground level to the
Skylight um on the on the front on the
proposed front
on that it
was originally on the proposed front so
when it was on the front
if someone was standing they would they
how far would they be able to
see CU I'm what I'm trying to do is to
get a comparison because obviously a A
vellu or a roof window is tilted so you
can't actually by the time you get to it
you're almost looking at the roof rather
than the
horizontal and therefore with the the
the new plans the windows a are much
larger but they're also um straight
alongside the wall I'm trying to gain a
a bit of an understanding in terms of
light but also from um an overlooking
perspective I wonder whether you can
just give some guidance on that please
um so the last application wasn't
supported with a section um so it' be
difficult for me to understand the angle
and and the height of it from the floor
space but um if you just give give me a
minute or so uh I will try to measure
the distance from the bottom of the
floor plan I think what I would say is
that those dotted lines that cross
through the middle of the house on both
sets of plans tell you where the floor
is within the
building so although we probably can't
give you without taking a good bit of
time accurate measurements you can tell
from the size of the front door that
it's likely that somebody could stand in
the velic with the head poking out
that's my expectation based on those
plans but the velc is on an angle rather
than straight and if you look at the
windows on the front they're quite
they're significantly
lower in accordance to the ground floor
if that's the dotted line if I'm seeing
it right that's my reading of the
plan uh councelor
lwood thank you chair um yes just on
that point if I could just add further
clarification please
um you you you you you pointed out the
the roof the floor positions on the
upper story um what the the the
interesting dimension for me is floor
Upper Floor story to the center of both
the norm the um Bellic window and the
traditional window is there are they the
same or is there a difference
please sorry could you just repeat your
question yes the point is if you're
standing on a
floor where the position of the window
is determines what you can see so with
the vellu window what is what is the
medial point of the window and what is
the medial point of the standard window
because if they're both of the similar
height you can see straight through in
the same way there is no restriction
with the
velc um the report carefully considered
overlooking impacts from front to front
um relationship setting out the distance
is I can provide that plan if that would
be of help uh no just to clarify my
question it is the distance from the
floor the floor itself on the upper
story to the center of the
windows I think for from from our point
of view as officers and the way we've
assessed it in accordance with the
SPD both the windows in the proposals
that members have before them today and
the windows which were in the originally
approved elevation provide overlooking
and need to be considered from a
perspective of um amenity and separation
distance um we've compared them
essentially within our report and
consider that they you know they are
equivalent neither the existing approved
proposal or the proposal members have
before them offer harmful
overlooking if I if I could just CL are
you saying that therefore that there is
no difference in terms of overlooking
between the two
schemes in terms of our SPD it doesn't
differentiate between a vellu window
which one can look out of or an ordinary
window in a vertical face of a
house Council pton um i' a question for
the legal officer
please
um can you ex can you just line for the
committee the the parameter that Define
what's a variation and what's a new what
then crosses the line to be a new
application there we go and yeah if you
could just give me a minute and I'll
come back to you on that
one any further questions in the
meantime I do have one myself um one of
the lines of questioning I believe for
the ward member was regarding the the
garden immunity space um and whether
it's changed I believe it's the same as
it was for the previous well the
approved application um but the number
of bedrooms for the house as it as a
whole has changed so am I right in
saying that the requirement for a
three-bedroom house as per our SD is
higher than the requirement for a
two-bedroom house and the previous one
was in Conformity with the SPD and the
current one as you've stated
isn't um that is my understanding so
Part D of the development requirements
SPD um sets out that an indicative
Garden area for a two-bedroom house is
40 square meters um whereas that
required for a three-bedroom house is 50
square meters um and there's no change
to the external garden
areas thank you very
much so sorry I was just looking there
was a very recent case on Section 73
variations um it was the case of Fisk um
so there was two distinct restrictions
on the exercise of the powers under
Section 73 and that it's must not
introduce a condition that creates a
conflict conflict or is inconsistent
with the operative wording of the
original plan and permission so the
description um which I don't think it
does in this case um and it must not
fundamentally alter the development
permitted by the original permission but
it doesn't expand on fundamentally alter
so that's all we have at the moment
okay any further questions points of
clarification no in which case we can
move to the debate who would like to
start don't all jump at
once okay thank you
Mr if it looks like a duck it walks like
a duck and quacks like a duck it's a
duck this is a new application for me
this is the approved elevation is in
essence a sort of one and a half story
velc property we've got a
twostory the height of the window is
less important than the fact there's a
significantly bigger proportion of
window to look through all of the issues
that were heard at appeal to me apply to
this and I would be looking to seek
support for a recommendation to refuse
um along the lines of the appeal about
the adverse overlooking impacts of this
um it is moving the goalpost and I'd
argue uh I just commented to my
colleague here that the use of the word
fundamentally is open to interpretation
so only the lawyers are going to get
rich but I'd actually question whether
this is suitable for a very application
in in really crude terms it's terms of
bungalow into a house if you want to
call it that so I'm not buying it and if
I can find anybody to support me I'm
going with that thank you very much
Council pton Council
Parry thank you chair I've got various
issues with this development um
predominantly there's a c cumulative
impact of lots of little tiny things
that just fall below the standard we
have the separation distances um we've
got the Garden area um and it's and then
we've obviously we've got the the the
increased height size and the impact of
the overshadowing and to me
the the new proposals come forward as a
bit of overdevelopment because they've
had permission for something and then
they've gone boom and to me it's not
just
overshadowing um it's not just the
cumulative impact it is
overdevelopment of from the original
site so I would like to Second councilor
pton for refusal on this application
thank you chair and and chair for the
avoidance of doubt I was trying to be
brief but councelor Paris uh coming with
uh the rest of the reasons or the
framework for the reasons we'd be
looking for for a refusal work Comm
we're work committee minded to to
support my proposal that's been
seconded thank you very much both any
further comments from Members councilor
Keithley thank you chair yeah well I'm
minded to go along with the councelor
pemberton's proposal um because I also
think that uh if I look at at those
plans it just seems like um
overdevelopment to me it's not what it
was it's not a minor variation it's
fundamentally different and those
particularly those front windows I see
as as much more overbearing in the
street scene and I don't like the fact
it's got a 40 square meter garden and
three bedrooms and it will be a family
house and to my mind um that ought to be
whilst I know the case officer said it's
recommendation I think that we ought to
um we ought to consider that that's
insufficient amenity space outside the
house thank you very much so I'll take
if councelor pton has made a proposal
I'm prepared to Second it I believe I
already had a second but thank you very
much councelor
Fleming um just to summarize what
everyone else has said too many
compromises for my for my thoughts and
uh I'll be supporting counc pem's motion
to to
refuse thank you very much uh councelor
passingham well um I wish to differ
because I can only see very minor
changes the the footprints the same the
the heights the same um and the changes
don't seem very harmful to me so I'm I
would like if I've got a second would
like to support the the the planning
officer's
decision okay thank you it looks like a
counter proposal um councilor Holmes um
yeah I'll have to go along with um with
Council passing him I I think the the
office assessment shows that there isn't
a change in in overshadow and I don't
think we
can necessarily have the evidence to go
against that um they said that that that
the G we we may not like it but I I
don't believe the the Garden area the
fact that it's a four-bedroom house is
is enough to to go against it and and
and fundamentally I think the the
comment on the street scene I think
there were some comments in in uh from
residents that it's actually a benefit
so I don't think we can use that for a
rejection so I'm happy to Second Council
passing it okay thank you very much uh
so just uh recap on that we've had two
proposals both of which have been
seconded the first is to refuse um
against officers recommendations that
was seconded first so that's one that
we'll hear first when we get to that
point would anyone else like to
contribute to the debate no um just for
my part in that um I I'm not completely
comfortable with the application I did
find that there were a couple of things
all under residential immunity within
the report which I feel do have an an
accumulation to to make me not want to
support it so that's U my opinion um now
Mr jeffes could you just clarify the
reasons before the first vote that' be
very useful thank you thank you chair
the reasons I've got here is that by
virtue of the larger windows and the
increased Eaves height there would be
adverse overlooking and
overshadowing um due to the lack of
garden space there would be insufficient
residential immunity uh for future
occupiers and that cumulatively the
compromises before you amount to poor
design and would be contrary to
development plan policy in that
respect through your
Che um just to clarify through cancel
Parry I think there was some question
councelor Parry was concerned about um
intensification of the site and general
overbearing I'm just trying to clarify
with my second whether she wants that
within there um chair if I if if we
could also include overdevelopment
because of the this the changes are
significant and therefore the it's the
cumulative impact resulting an
overdevelopment of the site
thank you I think that's going be clear
and has been noted okay so uh in which
case we can move to the vote um first
proposal um by councilor pton seconded
by councelor Parry is to refuse the
application uh wording to be delegated
to the officers uh can I see all those
in
favor seven all those
opposed three okay in which case C uh
committee resolves to refuse application
very thank you okay uh at this point I'd
just like to make um everyone aware that
item number five which is application
23961 ful Meadow Cottage alvon Lane
alvaston um has been withdrawn and so
will not be heard at committee uh this
evening
now move on to item number four item
37f tal Fields brails Road
ellsmore okay our presenting officer is
Tony hton when you're ready please take
it
away thank you chair this is the context
map for the site it's located in a
remote open Countryside location some
distance from W coat to the north it's
about one one and a half miles Tao is
around about 2 and 1 half miles to the
east brail's about 2 miles to the South
and shipston about four miles to the
west and the area is generally known as
asmore this is the committee site plan
in your papers the site contains a
disused agricultural building with hard
standings and is surrounded by
agricultural
land is the application site edged
red there some photographs of the
context of the site so this is looking
northwards uh coming towards the
crossroad so on the right hand side is
the existing agricultural building and
the land is behind that HED row this
would take this is a Google street view
um taken in March of this year
at the point where the uh the leaves and
hedge rows have lost their
foliage uh taken from the crossroads
looking due eastsh so you got the
application site as you can see there's
a certain amount of filtering from the
hedge row in the trees which would
obviously be um turned to more screening
during the summer months and in fact
Google street view for this part of the
uh the road uh is from July 2022 summer
months so it shows the change that the
um the leaves and the the Hedge RS can
bring about from filtering to a
screening uh exercise um got the
agricultural building in the background
there and the uh the access to that
which will uh be retained as part of the
proposals these are the existing
elevations uh these are taken from the
class Q application that's previously
been
approved but it Remains the Same
building for the purposes of this
current
application uh so we've got uh elements
of Yorkshire Yorkshire boarding uh
Yorkshire tber boarding and concrete
panels at the uh the bottom and it's a
steel portal frame building with
elements of it which are open uh and
elements
enclosed and if I show you some
photographs you can see the timber
cladding Yorkshire boarding the fiber
cement roof uh and the the portal
frame and then this is another view of
it uh and the general hard standing area
around it um which is largely devoid of
uh materials and
storage these are the proposals for pro
proposed site plan so
using the existing access slightly
realigning the existing access track uh
for the driveway creating four parking
spaces creating a cycle and Stor bin
storage area here converting the
existing building uh for residential use
there's some elements of new planting
dotted around the site and the retention
of the existing trees and hedge row
around the
boundaries
in terms of proposed
elevations so it's proposed to infill
the um the the walls which currently are
open so that will be a combination of
additional Yorkshire boarding uh there's
also render to the concrete
panels uh at the bottom elements of
extensive glazing to create new windows
doorways uh elements of that will have
shade Sun shading a Bree
laay uh you see some of the elevations
have floor to ceiling or floor to roof
uh glazed
elements and there'll be new doorways
and additional glazing in other
elevations proposed roof is to retain uh
and be repaired where necessary and to
incorporate two roof lights within
that and then in terms of of the floor
plans on the left is the ground
floor so this element here will be a
full two twostory height uh from ground
up to the
roof and that will contain a kind of a
mix of a living space dining space
kitchen space this element here will
have uh a new ceiling and it will create
two two bedrooms study snug and various
boot rooms and utilities and
bathrooms and then the first floor this
element will be a void space open up to
the roof and then three large on Suite
bedrooms in this
part uh chairman in terms of the updates
there are written updates on the update
sheet and I need to just further update
that verbally uh in regards of the
member site visit which was Tak took
place today and that was attended by the
planning case officer uh yourself chair
Council Adam plus councelors Keith Lee
and Parry uh no one else was in
attendance either from the applicants
agents or the
public chair the conclusions on this are
is the application proposes the creation
of a new dwelling within the open
Countryside and which is in principle
not in accordance with the council's
development plan policies and that there
are no material cons considerations
which are considered to outweigh the
policy
objection therefore the application is
recommended for refusal thank you thank
you very much uh we now move on to our
first Speaker who is Martin Cole from
braille's Parish
Council good evening uh yes uh you've
got three minutes um it's the button on
the right uh I'll give you a 30 second
warning
um before your time is up um otherwise
once you're comfortable uh feel free to
take it
away good evening chair and councelors
Martin Cole longtime resident farmer BRS
representing BRS Parish Council the
parish council supported this
application as they believe that the
application is a vast Improvement and
what is a deric barn and land with a lot
of rubbish and waste on it the site is
visible from a fair distance as you come
down the road from brails and is in a
bit of an ice all as it is the
applicants bought the plot with planning
permission granted and to take this away
seems morally wrong The Proposal will
enhance the area and improve the vision
of impact considerably the proposal and
the proposed Landscaping seems
sympathetic and enhancing and therefore
the parish C Council were in favor of
the
application I myself have farmed
adjacent to this land for at least 10
years in the past and I know the site
very
well can I um I have a extract from uh I
got two weeks ago um released by her his
Majesty's government um basically um on
class Q class Q is a PDR that allows
agricultural buildings to be converted
to residential use after going through
the prior approval process the
government has proposed revising the
size limits number and type of homes
that can be delivered through class Q to
increase the availability of homes in
rural
areas there is more but that is another
die
um one more
papers soorry uh I would like to bring
your attention
to
March this no I might be wrong on that
on this year is um the application
number 22
CQ proposal prior approval application
for the change of use of an agriculture
building into a larger dwelling C3 and
Associated building operations under
class uh Q Parts A and B of
GPD orders status change of use PA Grant
Class jk& M this is what you asked for
this is what was done on here previous
uh that concludes
my love you thank you very much uh
members do we have any questions for our
Parish
counselor uh no nothing coming forward
in which case thank you very
much okay our next speakers are Mr
Gregory bestman and Mike
Robinson uh gentlemen you have three
minutes between you uh how would you
like to split
that any
questions yeah I believe believe so
thank you okay uh in which case I'll
give you a 30 second warning before the
3 minutes is up otherwise uh is there
the button on the right to uh make the
microphone go
live okay thank you
counselor okay uh in which case um when
you're ready uh please take it
away chair members good evening and
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak about our
application after a very long search my
wife amandra and I bought taller Fields
paying a significant premium because of
the residential conversion consent it
was and is very neglected but we knew
this could be dramatically improved it's
our Dream to convert the barn into an
attractive ecologically Friendly House
for us our children and
grandchildren the land would be
transformed and restored with thoughtful
planting to create an environment with
great diversity of plant and Wildlife
this is a beautiful area of Countryside
but the land surrounding our property
has been adversely impacted by past uses
and the lack of sensitive
management we discussed our plans with
offices from the council in a
pre-application meeting and following
their advice obtained a second class Q
consent unfortunately we were unable to
work start work immediately due to
having to shield from coid as my wife is
registered as extremely vulnerable and
has serious health
issues however unknown to us the
neighboring site obtained a consent to
build a new barn last year and this is
now built as this was historically part
of the same land holding we were told
that this removed our development right
under class Q this was a devastating
blow for us and felt extremely
unjust it seemed to defy common sense
and cause significant stress we took
planning and legal advice and submitted
a full planning application using the
same designs that had received prior
approval for conversion under class Q
whilst we understand that the council's
policy as10 specifies only traditional
brick or stone buildings are suitable
for residential conversion this is not
in accordance with the more recent naal
policy which allows for conversion of
all types of redundant and disused
buildings in the
countryside our neighbors the parish
council and the local Ward member have
all been extremely supportive of our
proposals and are Keen to see this
present eyes saw change to benefit the
local community the visual landscape and
the environment they have also Express
consternation that our consents could
become invalid through circumstances
completely Beyond our control we ask
that you will also be able to support
this application and thank you for
listening to our personal
circumstances thank you very much well
within your time uh members do we have
any questions for applicant and their
agent no no oh councelor
Keithley yes thank you very much uh Mr
best bestman thank you for that um
I'm just interested to know um
what parameters there were around the
agricultural
holding because um
the the risk of losing the class Q seems
to hang on the the Farmland being split
up from what was historically the land
holding have you got a separate
agricultural holding now effectively
uh my understanding of the position is
that the uh agricultural holding for
class Q is judged as at
2013 rather than now so now our property
is on a separate title from the property
that was also granted permission to
build a b unbeknownst to ask right thank
you for that clarification so the date
that matters is is the is the 2013 date
in respect of the Agricultural hold
thank
you any further questions from Members
no in which case thank you very much for
your contribution this
evening okay uh we'll move on to our
final speaker who is the ward member
councelor Wally
hoggins good evening
councelor uh so you've got five minutes
I'll give you a 30 second
warning uh otherwise once you're
comfortable feel free to take it
away the recommendation before you from
officers is that this application be
rejected after having several
conversations with senior planners
regarding this application I suggest
that this recommendation is a reluctant
one based on the bewildering laws and
regulations that surround class Q
conversion rights not not only that
Stratford District planners have already
granted permission for the development
before you today on two previous
occasions with class Q permissions class
Q regulations allow for no personal
matters to be taken into consideration
the sickening realities of these
regulations have come to the for with
Talis Fields as simply because a
neighboring land owner has been given
permission by this planning Authority it
has made the the bestman class Q
conversion permission previously given
on two occasions
unimplementable the situation the bans
find themselves in is totally beyond
their control I've sat in this very seat
and at various other Council meetings
when coid has been accepted as a valid
excuse for the slippage in getting
things done and for redeveloping
buildings the terror of coid and the
consequences of catching it for Mrs
bestman is the very reason that lockdown
and shielding measures were so vital you
have been told in confidence about Mrs
be's exceptionally serious serious
medical condition this is the reason
that the building work was delayed when
the class Q conversion was valid it was
delayed because of Love pure and simple
that love meant that whilst dealing with
his wife's medical condition and nursing
her back to Better Health as well as
protecting her from coid was quite
rightly Mr be's priority by seeking this
permission Mr bestman is really seeking
permission to love his wife and to
validate the choice he made to protect
her rather than to start the conversion
of this ugly barn on this unsightly land
I remind you all that the freedom to
love anyone in this country is part of
the freedoms that our society enjoys
punitive consequences for loving someone
are abor and I put it to you that
failing to Grant this permission for
this application is exactly that as wh
Davis said what is this life if full of
care we have no time to stand and stare
no time to stand beneath the the boughs
and stare as long as sheep or cows no
time to see when Woods we pass where
squirrels hide their nuts in Grass no
time to see in broad daylight streams
Full of Stars like skies at night no
time to turn at Beauty's glance and
watch her feet how they can dance no
time to wait till her mouth can enrich
that smile her eyes began a poor life
this is full of care we have no time to
stand and stare if any of us at to
thrive and if civilized societies to
continue in this country moving forward
love must be allowed and Common Sense
must always Prevail very few of us are
lucky enough to be loved so deeply and
so completely as the bans love each
other if you have ever loved anyone with
every fiber of your being and wanted to
protect them from every harm I urge you
to Grant this permission that is because
the love of the one man for one woman
delayed the conversion work on this Barn
when the class Q permission had not been
invalidated by the permissions granted
by this Council for another barn on a
neighboring parcel of land this
application absolutely would adhere to
the National planning framework which
allows development to reuse redundant
and disused buildings and inhance the
immediate settings I believe that this
application more than satisfies policy
cs20 which supports the conversion of
existing Bel buildings into dwellings
where the D residential use is
acceptable in principle and the
conversion provides a satisfactory
safely living environment and Immunity
and obviously there would be no detri
detrimental effect on the amenities of
neighboring properties thank
you thank you very much councelor well
within your time uh members do we have
any questions for our Ward
member councelor Keithley uh thank you
chair thank you councilor wayy hoggins
for that um
just a couple of points um I'm just
reminded actually that three years ago I
tried to bring a motion forward when you
were the portfolio holder for
communities to do something about the
technical issues regarding class q but
unfortunately that motion was turned
down these are very complicated bits of
legislation can we just confirm for me
please that the original class queue
which was permitted on the 13th of May
2021 wasn't started at all and then
another application for a class Q came
forward well at least a year later why
was there a
delay I believe you're asking the wrong
person here councelor Keithley however
from the knowledge that I have with the
bans is and because of the severe
medical condition that you have been
notified about uh that is the delay
there is no you know I am not the
applicant here I'm merely speaking on
their behalf it is not for me to
speculate why the delay is there however
I am here to say that I am satisfied
that there were more than adequate
reasons for that delay um being made and
not just adequate there is not a single
person in this room that would
argue with the reasons for that delay
had they had the personal and uh indepth
knowledge that I have and may I also
remind you councelor Keithley that when
I was the portfolio holder for such a
short space of time that uh the class Q
conversions are exactly is is precisely
at national government level not at a
local level thank
you thank you um any further questions
for our Ward
member no in which case thank you very
much councelor W
hogins right we'll now move on to points
of clarification from our officers were
yes
counc
thank you um and again I've got a
question for the legal
officer um so a point has been
made that
leads in the applicant's mind and the
ward members
mind
that we have contributed to the creation
of this situation by virtue of granting
planning permission on a neighboring
side
with
a site
plan and then applying a wider site if
you will the entirety of the
Agricultural holding
land so the question for me
is I'm looking at some clarification
about the interpretation there on the
one hand this suggests the application
was considering sides a but in terms of
the question of class Q it's site B
which is a combination of A and B or C
which is a and b and equally to what
extent does the question of granting a
planning permission which then in
essence
precludes an exist an extant planning
permission come into play in other words
should we have
actually have we contrived to make this
situation and should we have done so and
I'm looking for some clarification but I
am really intrigued by the qu by the
notion
that
um the site that was granted the
agnot is the same as this site but it's
not because it's in the somebody else's
ownership because as I understand it
it's not the applicant that made this
new agnot so if you can pick the bones
out of that and help me I should be
really and if you need a minute that's
okay I will certainly give it a go
councelor peton um so just in relation
to what we would consider as the
established agricultural unit so that is
set out in um the general permitted
development
order so um when it comes to the agnar
so there is a restriction in class q
that says development is not permitted
by class Q if development under Class A
or Class B of part six of the schedule
add agricultural buildings and
operations has been carried out on the
established agricultural unit since and
then it sets out um there's a few
subsections since 20th of March 2013 or
where development under class Cube
begins after the 20th of March 2023
During the period which is 10 years
before the date of the development of
the class Cube begins it didn't begin so
it's the 20th of March
2013 but there is also um a par graph x
which specifically states that the
established established agricultural
unit means agricultural land occupied as
a unit for the purposes of Agriculture
on or before 20th of March 2013 which is
what the applicant was referring to that
is why it is a bigger area of land and I
believe um in class Q they have to
restrict the red line um to a certain
area so they couldn't include the the
whole agricultural holding um so the
class Q as it's for as it's for a
dwelling has to be restricted to a
certain
area may
I I'm sorry I've got I've got my simple
bummy boy head on I'm I'm sorry and what
I'm as I my interpretation of this is
these people buy a site okay and there
is an adjacent site in someone else El's
ownership but I think just just to point
out there it's not what what is apparent
now at this current date this is where
the 20th of March 2013 comes in so we
have to look back to that date so it's
it doesn't matter what is on the site
now which then brings me to the question
of are we in the business of granting
planning permissions that so that
destroy somebody else's planning
permission I I've got to struggle with
that and I'm and I'm looking to
understand that
because if I'm simple I've got two sites
here and I got person a and person B and
this seems to
be if some I can see David desperately
to try to try and join in and and and
make me understand this and that'll be a
that'll be a stretch hopefully I can
simplify this we're not interested in
land ownership as far as this is
concerned we're only interested in what
the agricultural unit was in March 2013
at that time it was the whole of this
this area two or three agricultural
Fields as shown on the plan
here the law is written in such a way
that you can achieve a prior approval
permission no so not a planning
permission a prior approval permission
for any amount of agricultural units and
any amount of class cues it's only
interested when you actually carry them
out so essentially as a local planning
Authority we handle the prior approvals
and we can approve a class q and we can
approve an agricultural building and
what it comes down to is effectively who
pulls the trigger first and if they get
their agricultural building built first
they can't go ahead with the class Q
because of the way the legislation is
written it disallows class Q to commence
on sites where they have recently
implemented an agricultural building
through prior approval so the answer to
your other question did the local
Authority create this mess no that
arises out of the way the legislation is
written but if I may I may come back um
I mean the Optics of this are
Dreadful we've we've we we we've
permissioned this building previously or
given prior
approval the I I I get yeah I'm just I
am just struggling because I've got the
2013 bit I've got everything else but
yeah just to cap it off the situation is
as set out in the report and the update
sheet there is effectively no class Q or
residential permission on this site
which amounts to a material
consideration in favor of your I have a
further question of the legal officer if
I
may um as concisely as you can please I
know I know I
know I'm try if somebody else has got
some question I need to form my
next thank you can the officers
explain purely there's a there's a
trigger process um the prior
approval followed the class Q for an
agnot would it
not and obviously it was a different
applicant's
name what duty of care does the council
have have in
informing the applicant for the class q
that an
agnot application has been submitted and
therefore if they got prior approval he
would need to or the applicant would
need to Fast Track and start his class
Q I I I just feel there you know need to
understand the notice for example um and
that would have been undertaken when we
were handling the prior approval for the
agricultural
building and that is as far as it goes
in terms of the
legislation what our duty is to to
discharge can I just come back on this
um Can the officers advise have we ever
in the history of Stratford District
Council had this appears to me a unique
situation have we had a similar
situation that has happened before or is
this totally new and
unique this is not totally new and
unique um we have had at least a couple
of other examples because of the way
class Q is written which requires not
just commencement like a normal planning
permission it actually requires
occupation of your dwelling within three
years we have had situations where
because of coid and because of other
factors um they have not managed to
comply with that and what you end up
with is effectively an unlawful dwelling
we've had applications to regularize
those situations in the
past thank you uh councelor keithy next
thanks
chair thank you chair um yeah couple of
questions for the uh the case officers
um a little bit confusion there I think
am I right in saying that the the the
steel portal framed agricultural
building the new one so the
agnot was permitted before the the
second of the class queue
applications first thing as far as I
read it unless there's some mistake on
the
dates the um agricultural building was
permitted in April and the um the second
class Q application the larger of the
two so when the class Q is expanded to
400 KN meters
yes you're absolutely correct in that
respect but as per page 18 of the report
what is mattering really is which is
carried out first yeah yeah I understood
that yeah but which which ones were
granted is in which order I was just
clarifying which granted
um there's a 10year restriction on under
part six for an agnot um in respect of a
Quee that's been permitted and I I can
understand that you know if a farmer
decides I'm going to make that Barn into
a house you can't then immediately
expect he's going to replace that house
barn with another barn doesn't seem
right does it there's a 10year
restriction it does it work in Reverse
in respect of an agnot reversing a
10-year rule for class
Q because if you wait 10 years after
you've got a class Q you can then apply
for agricultural building so I wanted to
know if it worked the other way around
around I think class Q effectively
limits that because it in um development
is not permitted in the case of a site
which was brought into use after 2013
for a period of at least 10 years before
the date date of development so I think
essentially your building has to have
been there 10 years before it AC Cruise
any class Q right in any case even if
you're using but the building is already
there as the point I'm making the the
the first Barn the tfield barn is there
now isn't it it's already
there so at that point it initially it
obviously had class Q rights it's only
when within that same agricultural
holding they undertook a prior approval
and implemented their prior approval for
agricultural um building that their
class Q right effectively Falls away due
to the conditions and limitations on
class Q okay and finally the buildout of
the Agricultural Barn there's a
three-year completion on that is it
complete in respect of having a
completion certificate or is it still in
process of being
built because both of these both of
these um permitted developments are
allowed 3 years to
completion you're asking about the agnot
building um I don't know the full
details of that case but I understand
that it is erected and
completed that then have a completion
certificate I don't know what process
they need to go through through building
regulations to whether or not they need
a completion certificate but not through
planning jump back to Council of
pton Council
of I'll order it this way you rais you
raised your question for
the
um uh David you mentioned this is not a
unique situation you mentioned that this
has come up and there were applications
to
regularize uh can you from memory tell
me what the decision at first instance
by the LPA was and if that if those
applications were subsequently appealed
what were the what was the planning
inspectorate's view I have a second
question for the legal officer after
that I'm not aware of any that have been
to appeal yet I'm aware of one which is
probably yeah I might be speaking
without knowledge um I think one is
still under consideration I think one
was approved under delegated powers so
one's been
approved okay uh using the extenuating
circumstances of coid one's under
consideration okay that's interesting um
a question for the legal
officer if we
assume that uh the the report is
absolutely Square about um class q and
the interpretation
thereof um to what extent as decision
makers can we choose to set class Q
aside um in I suppose I'm asking the
ultrav virus
question I think we we can't the class Q
cannot be implemented I think based on
the legislation we we haven't got a way
around that at the moment um it it is
quite clear in its date um and as that
stands and as the applicant has said
themselves they've sought legal advice
of the same opinion so okay yeah I was I
just wanted just to clarify that yeah
sorry could I just reinterpret your
question because I think it might be
helpful this application isn't going to
be determined in accordance with class Q
legislation it needs to be determined in
accordance with the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
that members should make a different
decision through you chair I was I was
clear on that I'm just feeling my way
through the thing if I
may thank you I will go to councelor
littlewood
next uh thank you um part of my
questions already been asked and
answered um but I'm I'm slightly
confused still because we've just heard
that we've had a situation in the past
where application has been granted
permission in a similar circumstance of
extenuate circumstances are the same or
similar to this um to the legal officer
please
um what are the consequences you've
you've repeatedly said this is unlawful
to to Grant it under class q but what um
or what are the consequences of this
committee granting voting to Grant
permission I think I just remind you
that this isn't a class Q application
this isn't class Q this one so I think
that that's IR relevant at the moment um
so and what what was your second
question um I I think you've answered it
by saying what you just said
okay I think the purpose of us talking
through the planning history of this
site and setting out whether the class Q
is extent is to help members understand
whether or not they should be weighing
the class q and the previous planning
history of this site in favor of the
applic ation that they have before them
we are setting out that they shouldn't
because it can't be implemented members
may consider that there are other
material considerations which Merit
weighing in favor of this application
and against the policies of the
development plan when making that
decision thank you uh councilor
Fleming um we we heard that uh the only
notification about the uh the the the
building next door was the fact that we
nailed a post we nailed a poster on a
telegraph poll somewhere and put an ad
in the paper was there any communication
between the planning Authority and the
applicant that this this uh situation
would wipe £100,000 off whatever it was
they paid for the building I just think
that if something is so um consequential
to somebody there was no communication
to tell them that that
happened there's no requirement in
planning law in the development
management procedure order or in the
general development management order
which requires the authority to do that
and I would remind members that many of
the decisions that we make in this
chamber do have those sorts of impacts
on people we we follow those
requirements in law and within our um
statement of community involvement which
sets out what the council shall do and
that is what we
follow Council
Perry thank you I just wonder whether
the officers
um as far as policy as10 is
concerned um the the site that is in
front of us um has an existing building
on it and because it has been used for
agricultural purposes and um machinery
and all of that side surely then that it
could
classify for reuse of brown Field Land
if it's been used AG as part of the
Agricultural
holding it's a it's a there is a
building standing there and that is
policy as10 Countryside and
Villages uh policy as10 at Point D
allows for the conversion to a
residential use of a redundant disused
building in open Countryside if it's
constructed of brick or stone or is
listed or of historic Merit it doesn't
allow for the conversion of of all such
buildings I think
the the uh report in this respect in
your agenda is is clear that if if
members were looking to support this
application it would be as a departure
from the development plan and members
are entitled to do that if they consider
there are material considerations that
warrant
it councilor
pton thank you I recall there was some
question I I suppose what I want to
understand is because we haven't got the
we haven't really got much
about well the question about the
architectural Merit of the building um I
recall there was some comment about the
building um and its uh its use of
construction methods and its zeroc
carbon nature um I'm asking the officers
to comment
on their view of the architect Ural
Merit of the
building the design I mean the
architectural Merit of what's been done
the building is the building so it it
you know you're not turning it into a
worldclass building but does that design
what architectural merits does that have
and you know in terms of how it is
changing that redundant building because
to me it it seems a reasonably neat
solution for a pretty rubbish
architectural uh uh pretty rubbish
agricultural
building well in terms of the existing
building as um Mr Jeffrey says the
policy as1 requires for for for it to be
in accordance with policy as10 we should
be looking at a brick building or a
stone building or a listed building or a
building of architectural or local
importance which looking at that it
doesn't to my mind qualify for any of
those with regard to the
proposals um it's a reasonable uh
conversion proposal I wouldn't say it
was outstanding uh in any particular way
but it um and you may take the view that
it's potentially inappropriate with the
amount of glazing in in that kind of
location and and some of the elements of
it it certainly doesn't look much like
an agricultural building once it's
converted and in an agricultural
landscape any further points of
clarification we've been quite
exhaustive on a number of topics no in
which case we move to the debate uh who
would like to
start cast Keith
Le yes thanks chair um well I think what
I start off by saying is I I really
empathize with the applicant who's found
themselves in a very difficult position
but you know this is um um there's
always a risk involved when land is
purchased with old bars and class Q when
when bar when Farms are being broken up
and what we seem to have ended up with
here is this agricultural holding has
ended up with two owners in competition
with each other to see who's the first
one to get a building built um so I do
empathize is a very very difficult
position to be in however what we've got
in front of us is an application for a
new house
in open Countryside the officers are
saying that there's no fallback position
to class Q because that doesn't exist I
can't see a reason to depart from the
development plan um the principle of
converting the modern building I'm just
reading from page 19 um is is against so
many of our policies as10 particularly
but cs1 cs15
cs16 I I can't find a reason why we
would wish to Grant this so that's my
position and I I would make a proposal
that we accept the officer's
recommendation thank you very much who
would like to go next councelor
pton yeah um I I too see I do empathize
with with the applicant
and the Optics of where we've got
to I think are not
good as a planning
Authority it would appear that through
and I know that it it seems clear that
class Q don't apply but we were happy
for this building to be built as it's
presented to
us in one set of
circumstances
and
um we now have a different set of
circumstances which have which have come
into play outside of the control of the
applicant and there is element of
natural Justice and I know that doesn't
play into it
um I do think it's a I think it's a I
think it's a good stab at improving that
building um I could just about be
inclined
to uh argue that there is some Merit in
the building and it crosses the
threshold of
as10 just
about um I'm happy to hear the rest of
the the debate but
I I I I it is usually I'm really clear
on where I want to go with this
stuff but I would like I would like to
find a way where we could stand up stand
this up uh in terms of of of allowing
this development uh but I'm interested
to see whether there's any I can Garner
any support for an argument along the
lines that it meets the the threshold in
as10 on the grounds of uh there is some
architectural Merit in the solution orbe
it that they haven't come up with
because perversely if that it strikes me
that if they came up with you know
adding brick and stone in there they'
are passed the threshold for as10
whereas this there's an element where
they're trying to be sympathetic but
improving of what we've got in terms of
what's there which is you know it's it's
not adding to the positive sum of the
place that is Al's
more um so I I throw that out there in
terms of whether any other
members uh have see any Merit in all of
that hey councelor
littlewood thank you chair um I I'm I'm
persuaded somewhat by councel pton
argument it does seem perverse that some
years ago we said this was fine and
today we can't and because of a a quirk
of of of law really um when when that
law was drafted nobody was considering
such a thing as a pandemic a lot of
consideration and easement has been
given on many subjects not just planning
because of coid and uh under the
circumstances I I I I think it would be
reasonable to look positively on this
with regards to building materials um
the possibility for for uh conditions
perhaps uh but at the moment uh I am
quite torn but I would like i' I'd
happily be persuaded by uh probably
somebody more eloquent than me to
actually support uh a proposal to um to
Grant
permission okay thank you councelor
par thank you chair I'm very torn with
this
application um my big stumbling block is
trying to find material planning reasons
because it's no longer class Q
um I think the circumstances are are
just appalling and it does also concern
me the probably the same agent sold the
neighboring plot of land suggesting they
could you know use build a bar um and
therefore defaulting the land that
they'd sold previously so there's an
element dare I say very close on
bordering um impr proprietary here um I
am just struggling to find a really
solid planning reason because nothing
would give me more pleasure than voting
to Grant
this but we have to look at policy and
and and I and it does con me and I just
I'm
just I think we all sitting around the
table would like to Grant this all of
us but we have to Grant on the basis of
policy and that is what I'm struggling
so um I shall sit back and and listen to
what other people here have to say but
it does concern me it wouldn't surprise
me the same agent sold the
neighboring agricultural holding um and
Market
as a potential for a new barn there
which has invalidated the planning
permission on on on this current site
which due to unforeseen
circumstances now when we have it's it's
a Pity it's not in Green Belt to a
certain degree because we can we can
always use you know extreme personal
circumstances when it's green belt but
this isn't Green Belt um so I shall wait
to hear what others have have to say but
it is a very difficult situation and
it's certainly something I've never come
across before of being on the planning
committee for 13
years thank you councelor councelor
H thank you chair yes um I virtually
agree with everything that councelor par
has said and the difficulty is
um for a proper planning reason and um I
wait to hear any body else on
that okay um I'll jump in with my
thoughts at this point um because I
think there's a lot understandable
deferral to to other opinions and it is
an incredibly emotive application that
we have before us I think the thing that
is clear is that we do have a policy
background that we have to tie it back
to if we want to make any decision this
evening and that is how we work as an
authority in terms of
planning the prior approvals are under
government legislation and we are the
authority that processed them but this
is a full application in front of us
which is judged under our core strategy
and Associated documents on that basis I
think we all have incredible sympathy I
don't think I've had an application in
front of me that I haven't felt more
strongly about and I think a lot of the
councilors around the table would say
the same thing I though cannot find the
policy basis to go against the officer's
recommendation on that basis I'll second
councelor Keithley would anyone else
like to contribute to the
debate
no in that case we have the proposal
under a second to refuse the application
in line with the officers
recommendations can I see all those in
favor
please
five all those
opposed two three
abstentions
two in which case committee resolves to
refuse application uh
23 sorry make sure um
37f T Fields brails
Road okay members we've got one more
application this evening which is item
six application 22
ful uh Stratford minigolf swans Nest
Lane Stratford on aen our presenting
officer is
sarahy uh once you're situated please
take it
away thank you
chair wait a second till that starts
sharing
sorry
oh I'm not sure
sorry there we
go thank you chair the site is located
in statford Stratford upon aen within
the recreation ground with the
application site denoted by the red line
on this plan the site is located within
the conservation area area of restraint
and flood zone 3 and is within the
setting of the grade two star listed
Royal Shakespeare theater The Wider
Recreation ground is designated as a a
local green space in the neighborhood
plan oh sorry also you can see a the
green dash line that denotes a public
right of
way uh this is a full planning
application for the Redevelopment of
Stratford mini golf here we see Google
satellite imagery of the site seen here
where my cursor is I'm denoted by the
arrow the Red AR at the
bottom uh with the raw Shakespeare
theater and River aen to the north the
Bowling Club adjacent and to the
northwest of the site north and west
west of the site the recreation Grand
car park is located to the east of the
site the proposed site plan shows the
new proposed layout sought through this
application including that of the two 18
hole
courses a cafe kiosk seating area and
Central pathway are also proposed with
the cafe and seating here and the
pathway seen in an l-shape
here some of the holes will include
miniature structures including a 700 mm
High replica of Shakespeare's birthplace
a 1500 mm temporary fence and a new
hedra proposed around the entire site
boundary almost sorry almost the entire
boundary denoted by the purple dashed
line around
here the existing trees are proposed to
be retained seen here at the
bottom these images show an example of
the type of fencing proposed around the
perimeter of the site native hedging is
also proposed to screen the fencing and
the development would would be confined
within the existing site boundary as
seen on the previous
slide then image is taken facing
Southeast across the river Raven and
shows the site one View From the Terrace
alongside the Royal Shakespeare Theater
the bows Club is seen over here if you
can see my cursor on the right hand side
of the
image this photo has taken facing the
Northwest with the area of the proposed
new first course uh seene in the
foreground in the Royal Shakespeare
Theater to the
rear here we Face the Southwest with the
grade one list of Holy Trinity Church
seene in the background
here we Face West with the Aven in the
background and the area of the proposed
second course would be located in the
foreground
here this image is also taken facing
west but it's taken from slightly
further back you can see the roal
Shakespeare theater on the right
again there are some updates in the
update sheet relating to the recommended
conditions uh chair the development is
acceptable and principle and subject to
the conditions securing mitigation and
amongst other things there removal of
the proposed pening after a period of 3
years and the scheme is considered
acceptable on balance the recommendation
is therefore to Grant Subject to the
conditions as detailed on page 43 and 44
of the agenda and in the update sheet
thank you thank you very much okay our
speakers on this item are Mr Mark knot
and Chris
Jones good evening gentlemen thank you
for your patience this evening uh so
you've got three minutes between you um
I understand just me yeah just be
talking jolly good I'll give you a 30
second warning otherwise when you're
free when you're ready take it away
brilliant thank you chairman for giving
me the opportunity to address the
committee this evening I'm not going to
say too much as I think the officer's
report sets out all the facts to be fair
fully um we' worked hard with the
planning officers to get a solution
that's acceptable to everyone in terms
of the fence and to that extent we have
followed the examples of other fencing
that is already present at the
recreation
ground uh the fencing is very important
to us as a business as we're wasting
obviously a considerable am of money to
rebuild those courses um as well as the
ongoing increase rent to Stratford
Council um and we would not be able to
suffer from the vandalism antisocial
behavior of which there have been many
instances since we started we run it
currently um from March
21 um we've agreed to carry out
extensive Landscaping to to screen the
fence with Native hedging uh which would
obviously also help from a biodiversity
aspect
um we're confident that Stratford
Adventure Golf will help support the
local economy by providing activity for
locals and visitors more opportunity for
participation especially from local
schools um as well as employing local
residents um as we have done to date um
i' therefore ask that uh for support the
application and hope you agree that the
development as a whole will make a valid
contribution to the
town that's it thank you
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any
questions that was easy no okay in that
case thank you very much for your
contribution so there are no further
speakers registered um which means we
move to points of clarification members
do we have any points of clarification
from our officers nothing from the table
in which case we move on to the debate
who would like to start councilor
pton
it's
on I would like to propose granting
planning permission in line with offer's
recommendation and look for a
seconder thank you very
much councelor Fleming looking to Second
anyone else like to speak on this item
no in which case we have a proposal and
a second to Grant in line with the
officer's recommendation can I see all
those in favor
that's unanimous it's unanimous in which
case uh committee resolves to Grant
application
ful
um item seven urgent business no urgent
business in which case I declare the
meeting closed thank you very
much